In this video, I'm going to show you
exactly how I start my day trading
career over if I had to begin from
scratch and how you can follow the same
30-day roadmap to do it step-by-step.
Before I ever reached the point of
making three to five thousand dollars
single profit days, I wasted five plus
years and tens of thousands of dollars.
[music] If I'd known the foundations and
the processes I'm going to share with
you today, it would have changed [music]
everything. Here's the plan. I'm going
to give you a complete 30-day roadmap
showing you exactly what to focus on
each phase of your first month. We'll
start with trading foundations and a
simple way to actually understand
trading. We'll cover the websites and
tools you need to follow this process.
Next, I'll show you how I rewired my
brain with trading psychology, the
single most important element that can
make or break your success. After that,
we'll go over the simple math behind
professional trading and then dive into
a crash course on technical analysis and
the exact principles I use every day.
From there, I'll show you how to build
and test your own strategy and by the
end, we'll apply everything in real-life
market scenarios so you can see it
working in real time. So, let's talk
about the simples of how the markets
work. Over here, I have a chart open.
Let's not worry about anything else
other than just how and why the market
goes up and down. This is a
representation of the mass psychology
and people trading this market. It
doesn't matter what you're looking at,
but that is what price of these up and
down movements represents of buyers and
sellers coming in of either traders and
investors like you and me or big banks,
big hedge funds, algorithms, everyone
that is a participating in this market.
And essentially, what causes the price
to move down or up over time is the
imbalances between buyers and sellers.
What caused the market to move down
right here was there was a lot more
people wanting to sell than buy. And
this imbalance pushes the market down
and then eventually, it got to a point
where that imbalance was filled and then
it flipped and a lot more people started
to want to buy. There's a lot more
demand in the market and so that's what
pushed this up over time. And these
little imbalances, you can see if you
zoom more into the chart, will go up and
down over time in the smaller points in
the market. And this is what volatility
is called, these up and down movements.
These create on a smaller time frame
trading opportunities that we'll talk
about later. Now, how you make money
trading is let's say this is a stock
chart of let's say Apple. And down here,
it's trading at $100.
If we buy 10 shares at $100 and it moves
up here to let's say 105 and we sell
those 10 shares, the amount of profit
we'll make is this difference of $5 that
it moved up times the 10 shares we
purchased. So, we will make $50 over
that time frame trading. And so this is
the whole idea of how you make money
trading is you buy at a certain price
and then sell another price to make that
difference. And so this is actually a
chart of the S&P 500 futures. And
normally, over a year of long-term
investing, you can expect to get, let's
say, 10% return on average long-term
investing in the S&P 500. This is your
basic safe investment. And so if you
took $100, you would get $110 after 1
year. But when it comes to trading, you
can take something like that, $100, and
you can turn it into
>> [music]
>> $300
in a matter of days or weeks or minutes
depending on your strategy and your time
frame that you're trading. But [music]
unlike long-term investing is you can
lose all of this $100 in that same time
frame as well. Compared to if you invest
in the overall S&P 500 futures stock
market, well for that $100 to go to
zero, the stock market has to go to zero
and you're probably going to have bigger
issues than losing your $100 if that
happens. So, there's a lot more risk
involved, but the reward is higher if,
again, you can master some key steps.
And so here's a quick example of a trade
I took on a 1-minute chart. So, it's a
lot faster-paced. I saw essentially a
couple key factors of why I thought it
was important to buy down here and then
I thought the market would reverse up
and then I bet that it would go up
risking $1,700.
And then if it goes up here, I make, you
know, about $5,000. I think on this
trade, I made roughly $4,500
over about 15 minutes. So, that's really
fast-paced. Again, [music] there's
trades where I lose essentially that
$1,700 in 15 minutes. So, that risk is
there as well, but the math and strategy
over time play out in my favor. We'll
talk about how that works in a minute.
But you're not going to be making that
much money right away. It took me years
to scale my account to be risking that
much at once. When I first started, I
was risking
>> [music]
>> $50 a trade. And over time, I scaled and
got bigger [music] and bigger. And so
what the trading journey looks like as
you start out, you're probably going to
be either losing money slowly over time
or you're going to be break even and
really not making that much because it's
just going to take time to get used to
what you're doing, how trading works,
and mastering your strategy and your
emotions and psychology that we'll talk
about in a second that really make or
break your trading. And then eventually,
what will happen is you will start to
find some consistent profitability when
you nail down a trading strategy. But
because you're trading small size, it's
not going to be that much right away.
But don't focus on the money initially.
That is what ruins traders. Even me
recently when I sized up to this current
size I'm at, I went on emotional roller
coaster spiral [music] and lost a lot of
money because I started focusing on the
money way too much. I started thinking,
"Holy cow, I can now make $5,000 in 15
minutes." And [music] that really messed
with my ability to consistently execute
the strategy. But eventually, as you
size up, that $10 will start to become
$50, $100, $200,
>> [music]
>> and then your equity curve and how much
you're making will go parabolic in
essence. It'll be an exponential graph
because you're not making $10 anymore.
You're now making $100 and then you're
making $1,000 per trade. And so that'll
slowly happen over time, years
potentially, but that's where the real
money comes [music] trading. Now, when
it comes to what you should actually
trade, you can choose anything that you
want. [music] But over my years, I trade
stocks, options, crypto, forex, and
futures. And what I've realized over
time is futures [music] is the best
thing to trade if you want to start out
with a small account but still be able
to get a lot of leverage. Trading the
S&P 500 futures has something like 450
to 500 times leverage, which is insane.
>> [music]
>> But essentially, what it allows you to
do is participate in trading where you
only need $50 in your account [music] to
get started. I would suggest having a
little bit more than that, maybe
something like 500 [music] because if
you lose one trade, you know, you're
going to have to redeposit money. But
you can essentially get use this $50 to
enter in a trade and even be risking
less than that, maybe even $20. We'll
talk about and I'll show you some trade
examples [music] in a minute here. But
what it allows you to do is able to say,
"Hey, I want to risk $20 in this trade
[music] and I will try and triple that
and make $60." And so you can start out
really small because again, going back
to this journey is in the beginning, you
need to just be focusing on learning
because you're going to lose money most
likely or you're going to just be break
even for a while. You may have streaks
where maybe you make money for a week or
two, but then you'll give it back up
because the market is really, really
hard to trade over a long period of
time. There's [music] different market
cycles that cause you to have to adjust.
And if you don't know how to do it
because you're not experienced, you'll
lose money. Now, when it comes to a
trading platform and tools to use, I
highly recommend checking out this
platform. It's what I've used for over
five years now for trading futures. It's
called NinjaTrader. I'll leave a link
for it in the description below or you
can use this QR code. And it's super,
super powerful for trading futures. You
can easily draw and use any basic
charting software you need, but the
ability to be able to manage trades
super easily by moving up your, you
know, your stop loss or you're moving
around your targets of profit just with
a click of a button and a chart. And as
well, a tool that I have created for it
where I can easily have the system tell
me how many contracts I need to trade.
We'll talk about it in a minute to, you
know, risk a certain target and, you
know, continuously stick to that proper
risk is super, super powerful. And the
biggest thing is what this will give you
access to is your candlestick charts,
which are super important for really
deep diving into what is going on with
the markets and reading the price
movements that will really, really help
you in the long term. So, some quick
basics on how to read candlesticks
[music] is a green means that the market
or the price moved up over that period.
You can have a candlestick represent
[music]
1 minute, 1 hour, 5 hours, 1 day, 1
week, 1 month. You can have them
represent any period of time you want,
or even 10 seconds. [music]
But, what they mean is that this means
that the price moved up, and then red
means that the price moved down over
that period. And so, what you can have,
let's say this is a 1-day candlestick,
where this candlestick right here
represents 1 day's worth of market
[music] movement. And so, you have it to
where the day opens up here, the price
moves down to here over the day, moves
all the way up here, and then comes back
here and closes at the end of the day.
And so, that's showing you the price
movement over 1 day. And then, on the
flip side, the same thing for this,
[music] but it's flipped, where the
market opened up here, moved up here,
sold off, and then closed out here. And
so, this could represent a day, a
minute, [music] or even seconds. And so,
you can see, if you look at my charts,
hopefully it's not too confusing, but I
have white for up bars and blue for down
bars. [music] This is all about the
trading psychology behind seeing red and
green bars. They're a lot more jarring,
or mentally triggering, at least for me.
And so, that's something I did over
time. And so, let's talk about some of
the trading psychology and how to rewire
your brain so you don't go into a losing
test spiral, [music] like I did
recently. And it'll hopefully help you
save years off of trading [music] and
losing a ton of money. This is what can
really make or break traders. Even for
me, a seasoned trader that knows what to
do, I fell into an emotional state,
skipped the rules that I know to follow,
and
>> [music]
>> lost a ton of money. And so, no matter
how good your strategy is, if you can't
consistently [music] execute it, you're
going to lose money, no matter what.
Now, a huge thing to avoid when you're
first starting out is the idea of a
really high win rate strategy. [music]
Winning in trading feels really good,
but the reality is a lot of strategies
have a 40 or 50% win rate, or even less.
Generally, I have a smaller win rate
because I am risking a smaller amount to
make a larger amount. So, I don't need
every trade to win, because when I'm
right, I make a crazy amount of money,
and when I lose, I lose a lot less. And
so, you don't need a really high win
rate to be consistently making money
over time. Losing is a part of trading.
[music]
Another huge one is being okay being
wrong. I had a great, almost
perfect-looking trade that I entered in
a couple days ago, and the market ended
up reversing on me, and I lost money on
the trade. And so, losing that, you
know, makes you think, "Oh, well, it was
a bad trade. I shouldn't have been in
it." But, making money on a trade, or
losing money on a trade, doesn't mean it
was good or bad. The outcome doesn't
necessarily mean it was a good or bad
trade. I thought this trade was great.
All you can really control when it comes
to trading is entering in, and then
whatever happens after you enter the
trade, if the market decided to go down,
or goes up, that's out of your control.
And so, focus on what you can control
when it comes to trading, and realizing
that losing isn't a bad thing. High win
rate isn't necessarily good. Making
money on a trade doesn't necessarily
mean it was a good trade, or losing
mean it was a bad trade. The biggest
thing you want to do is focus on the
process of consistently doing the same
thing [music] every time, because that's
what you can control. And so, when it
comes to trading, what you want to be
focusing on instead is how much you're
risking every time, and how much you're
looking to make. You want a good
risk-reward ratio
>> [music]
>> that is in your favor. That's what I
found to be the most important thing
over time. And so, for me, my current
risk-reward ratio is I risk $1,500.
I look to make two or three times that
risk, [music] or even sometimes four.
And so, if I can risk $1,500 and make
$4,500 or $6,000 on a trade, I don't
have to be right very often to make
money over time. I can lose $1,500
[music]
every now and then, because when I'm
right, I make a lot of money, and that
risk-reward is [music] positive over
time. And so, that's where the trading
math will really come [music] in your
favor in trading. You can have a ton of
losses, where you're losing a hundred
every time, but every now and then, when
you do win, you're winning way more. And
so, over time, you know, even though you
lost six trades, you lost $600, those
three winners, you made 850 bucks.
[music]
So, your average winner is around three
times your risk. And so, over time, you
know, you have a 70% loss rate and a 30%
[music]
win rate. But, over those 10 trades, you
made $250. And so, that's where the math
and the long-term consistency plays out.
And so, if you get [music] upset over
these losses and they derail you, you
don't have time to let the math play out
in your favor and the strategy's favor.
If I go to my chart here on NinjaTrader,
I have actually created a tool that
allows me to say, "Okay, if I want to
enter in, let's say here, and my stop
loss here, I want to, let's say, target
$50 of risk [music] every trade." You
can see that, depending on where I enter
in the trade and where I put my stop
loss, it'll adjust automatically how
many contracts I need to trade. So, this
is super easy for targeting a certain
amount of risk every time as
consistently as possible. If I trade
just one contract, I can risk $28 if my
entry is in here and my stop loss was
here. And so, you can trade a really
small amount and practice this over
time. And then, it'll show you, "Okay,
if I get out here, 1x, [music] 2x, 3x."
And this allows you, and I literally use
this every trade to help me know how
much I need to
>> [music]
>> enter in on to target my risk. And so,
I'll leave a link for that in the
description as well. And so, to quickly
jump into a crash course of technical
analysis and how to look at a chart and
read it, is there are a few key things
that I have stuck to over time that
helps simplify my trading, not make it
too complicated so I can focus on
consistently executing the same thing
over time to help me be consistently
profitable. But, as well as let's just
go over those main things so you kind of
know what to focus on [music] when
you're trading. And so, for me, I
realized over time that having a ton of
indicators didn't really help. [music]
Just looking at the swings over time
really became very important for me. And
really, all I look at is, if you look at
the swings in the market, they make your
uptrends and your downtrends. And
downtrends are signified by lower lows
and lower highs, and uptrends are
signified by higher highs and higher
lows. [music] And looking at those, you
can create things like support and
resistance off of when there are
multiple swings in one area. You know,
based on what we talked about earlier,
the supply and demand, anytime the
market comes up here, well, sellers
really start to outweigh the buyers, and
they push the market down anytime
[music]
it comes up to this zone. And so, that's
how I like to look at this and say,
"Okay, well, when it comes up here, I
want to bet that it's going to go down
potentially. And when it comes up here,
I bet that it's going to go down." And
eventually, you know, it'll eventually
break because of all these levels
eventually break in the market. But,
that's a really key way to help read the
market. Another one is a trend line.
It's just literally, you can just look
at It doesn't match the market all the
time, but some downtrends in the market
are very well matched to a trend line,
where the market comes up and hits it
multiple times. And so, every time it
comes up to this trend line, you can
say, "Okay, well, I want to, [music] you
know, take a trade here and bet that the
market's going to go down, risking
something like, let's say, if you're
doing a small account, risking $40, and
betting that it's going to go down, and
making 100 [music] bucks." And so,
that's how you can scale and trade over
time. And then, the biggest indicator
that honestly grounds all of my trades,
and [music] I use for every trade I
take, is if we go to a Most NinjaTrader
has this, and a lot of other platforms
will, as well, is if you just type in
fair value gap indicator and turn it on,
what it will do is it will draw these
boxes. [music] And what these boxes
essentially mean is the market has had
an unhealthy movement. So, in the
market, you have a move up, generally
has pullbacks in it. And because of
that, it helps balance the buyers and
sellers. But, you can see here, this is
a great example [music] we recently had,
is the market here sold off really hard.
You can see maybe these red boxes for
saying that it was having an unhealthy
trend to the downside. And because of
that, once that trend kind of slowed
down, started to get [music] choppy
here, it reversed higher. And this is
where something like me, I would come
in, and I would say, "Okay, I really
like this signal. It's overextended.
It's coming to, let's say, a support
zone, where I think it's going to go
up." And I would pull up my drawing
tool, uh my risk-reward tool, and say,
"Okay, I want to bet in when the market
breaks up here." You know, as I'm seeing
this pullback, and then I put my stop
below this swing, because I like using
the swings in the market. And then, I
would ride the move up, and And I would
capture, you know, in this case, if you
went for 3x on this trade, you'd make
150 bucks [music] risking $50. And so,
that's how you can trade the market
effectively by looking for patterns like
this. Now, this is an extremely
oversimplification
of this. I have tutorials that dive way
more into technical analysis and reading
charts. I'll link a video up here. But,
what you want to be doing is creating a
trading [music] plan for yourself. Now,
I've got a 90-day trader roadmap PDF
guide that lays out a ton of this that
you can download for free using the link
below or this QR code. But, to go into
some nuts and bolts of that right now,
what you want for your rough trading
plan to really try and make trading a
business because you need to treat it
like a business. If you treat trading
like gambling, which a lot of people do,
you will end up losing your money. And
so, first what you want to do to build
this foundation is you want to learn a
bunch of different strategies. You want
to find a strategy that you find feels
[music] simple and fits your trading
personality and how you want to trade.
If that's trading a 1-minute or a daily
chart, but then next you want to create
>> [music]
>> a document that has your rules laid out.
You want to write this down and you're
essentially your plan of what you're
doing [music]
going into every single day. What I do
is I show up [music] right before the US
stock market opens, and then I look for
a few key factors of [music] big
momentum moves that happen in the first
30 to 60 minutes in the morning. And
then, if I see a move like that, and
[music] if it aligns up with my rules
that I have set, that's when I enter in
on a trade and bet that the market is
going to go higher, and I [music]
look to take a profitable trade based on
that. And if I don't see those factors
show up, I don't take a trade. I do
[music] not stick around looking at the
charts all day trying to capture every
move that the market [music] has. What
has worked for me over time is sticking
to something very, very simple and
repeatable. From there, once you have
made your strategy and rough plan, open
a demo account on NinjaTrader and start
practicing it. I highly recommend that
you demo trade without real money first.
There's going to be a lot of stuff going
on in the market that just learning to
read the market and look at what's
happening is really, really hard over
time. I mean, just looking at this
morning, I didn't take that trade this
morning because if you can see, the
market opened up here and it just sat
here and chopped around for 2 and 1/2
hours. Eventually, it got moving, but
those first 2 and 1/2 hours, if you're
not used to being able to recognize
that, you could lose a lot of money. And
so, learning to go with the different
swings and moves that the market has
takes time. So, to dive more into my
strategy and futures and how they work,
check out this video right here. It'll
lay out everything in it you need to
know about reading charts, mastering
futures, and [music] executing a
consistent strategy every day in the
market.